I I I ju Just with the access thing I
you know the first film the first film I
ever did was uh uh World Trade Center
right Oliver Stone and you know man I I
I had no idea I didn't grow grow up
around any actors I had no idea about
like research and that you know research
to me was books man I I had no idea that
Oliver was going to take us down to the
bus terminal and that we were going to
meet these Port Authority cops and that
we could go out with them every day for
a month that he was going to facilitate
that I had no idea that that was even
a thing and I got to know these guys I
played this guy named Chris amaroso who
died in the when the towers went down he
left the youngest Widow and and and and
his daughter uh his his wife Sophia and
his daughter Jamie and uh I met these
two guys uh Sergeant finny and and
officer Fairbanks who were his two best
friends right and I couldn't believe the
level of trust that these guys put put
in me and and when we were doing that
film I had written a letter I had
written a letter to Chris's Widow just
asking for her blessing that I was going
to be doing this and and and and and
just to say look his memory is belongs
to you but if you want to be a part of
memorializing this you want to talk to
me about Chris I would love that and I'm
just some [__] actor from from
Hollywood and and and this you know uh
this is sacred to you and you know the
stud I was just you know the studio shut
it down the producer said you can't
reach out and in the film they had ended
up taking all of the wives and the and
and uh the children's names out of the
movie and and they had completely taken
that part out because the wives had
gotten together and said they didn't
want to be a part of it and that had it
had bothered me so much that I couldn't
reach out to her and then on my last day
uh of that month of going around with
finny and Fairbanks uh they say hey we
got a surprise for you kid and they they
they put me in a car and they took me
out to to her house and I got to meet
her and and and now we've kept in touch
and we've become and uh you use the word
access uh I I I couldn't [__] I mean
to me at that point cops were guys that
beat me up cops were guy like I I didn't
you know but but I I had
uh the power to to to change your entire
[__] idea of of of people and and the
power of get going into their lives and
being able to walk among them and walk
with them and and for me that's always
been my uh armor that's always been if
if I can do that then I can walk in
there and I can do anything if I can
walk among them if I can call them
friends and share space with them and
I'm just wondering I guess the the
I felt that now and and and I see it now
that you know on a small scale people
know who the [__] I am and what that
does and what that that allows me to
have the kind of conversations I have
and how much richer my life has gotten
how much better of a dad I've become
better friend better husband better I'm
I'm so unbeliev more more so than than
than you know my dream of being able to
you know raise my kids because I get to
do the thing I love more than anything
else in the world this access is in is
incredible and I guess there's a there's
a commitment to to to to researching
these roles and to to for a means for
the end and I'm just wondering at a
certain point did this lead to what
you're doing now was it are they are
they they the same probably the same
hunger and probably the same
satisfaction of curiosity but also I
think because look you and I have
probably benefited a great deal from
caring about what we do and therefore
including whatever I can eat to do it
well right and we also know that in the
mechanics of film making so for example
um U Bradley Cooper has a a moment in
American Sniper where he's taking his
sniper
rifle down or packing it away and in in
just that
moment he's handling that weapon in a
way that licenses everything else that
sell just that moment right
we know a lot of times we'll go out and
do the the research on everything and
sometimes it gets in our way on the
movie and you're sitting there and
you're telling the director that's not
how they do it and yet this little
poetic license is going to make the
scene that works work or not and you got
to tell a whole lifetime in two hours
and there's going to be short hands and
so sometimes the the you know that
hunger for the reality to represent it
to honor
it you know can we can lose track and
sometimes it's about and this is just a
learning curve for me where you try to
get selective about the things at the
same time the thing that's most
important more than everything's got to
be just like the real thing which
generally speaking does get in the
way there's the confidence that comes
with having put in the time and to be
able to offer options based on
observations that you just had by being
so focused on it and I saw this um what
had to be extemporaneous
um um closing argument of a debate and
it had to be extemporaneous because
there was no way that this person could
have known where the debate was going to
go it was a debate on political
correctness with sort of um odd um bed
fellows as it were uh partnering on one
side of the debate about political
correctness and that was the partnering
of Steven fry with Jordan
Peterson and on the other side it was
Michael Eric Dyson and Michelle Goldberg
of the New York Times and at the end of
it stepen fry and God I recommend this
to everybody to see just look up step
fry closing argument he summarizes and I
it's an indirect way of addressing what
we're talking about
but I don't want to give away too much
but I he he talks about that there's a
kind of obligation to a certain people
will find it ironic that I'm saying this
um
lightness and he's celebrating
uncertainty admitting that he he's
opposed to anything any
Orthodoxy and and as it relates to
acting
um the orthodoxies especially as young
actors can get this into trouble and and
I think I recognized that pretty early
on so that for
example let tell you two quick funny
stories well three chapters one was the
first movie I did was TAPS at a military
academy I'm going to tell you we didn't
we they they sent us through that
training and we were taking it so
seriously I must have been 21 years old
22 whatever I was my last scene in that
movie I play the best friend of the
leading actor Tim Hutton and then we've
got this one crazy guy who Tom Cruz
played who's starting a riot it's a war
with the National Guard I'm trying to
I'm kind of the conscience for Tim
trying to tell him not to get in trouble
with this
thing and uh so all these Cadets have
taken over the military school they've
gotten into the Armory and they got and
she's got like an M60 and Tom Cruz does
in the window looking down at the
National Guard he's just wants a war and
Tim Hutton in that dramatic last scene
sees him as Tom Cruz looks up at us and
says it's beautiful man beautiful and he
starts the the gun Tim does the kind of
classic no moment you know and runs and
jump and I see my best friend Tim going
for for the the Tom Cruz character and I
I just want to get him and I and so so
here's what happens I get to set now the
wall is all squibbed it's all you know
they took five hours of the previous day
to pre-rig it with all these automatic
weapon fire and
U and so we we're going to walk it
through once before let's get make sure
the guys and Tim goes racing in and they
say you know they're not setting them
off yet right and I hit the deck and I
start scrambling to to get to Tim and
grab his body pull it but because he's
been shot I'm supposed to grab pull him
out and I'm
dragging Sean
Sean you you just went right out of the
shot har Harold
Becker is still a great friend today and
I he he said just you know they
basically wanted me to run through the
hail of
gunfire and I argued like I had been in
the business my whole
life and it was a The Producers were
brought down they like like this was not
going to happen I I'm not going to do
this and I had never heard this thing
before which is
look do one this way and then we will
rrig the wall you know and we'll do you
know and we
did well I go to the avco
cinema and when the movie comes out and
I'm sitting in the back
row and I'm watching the movie and I've
never seen a movie I was in
before and just at the moment that I am
going to Tim the guy having no idea that
the actor playing this role in front of
him was sitting behind him this guy says
hit the dick
[__] and and that set me up for not
listening to directors for long time um
and then and sometimes still uh
but but on this kind of you know this
Devotion to the craft if if there were a
movie about actors researching yeah
there's been there's been a comedy about
it it's not as funny as
[Music]
mine